[Musique]
et bonjour stanislas guérini merci
beaucoup d'autres invités politiques ce
matin êtes mise de la transformation et
de la fonction publique est toujours
délégué général de renaissance et le
parti de la majorité présidentielle en
détention pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale bonjour julien lécuyer bonjour
yann bonjour monsieur le ministre la
voix du nord on ne présente plus mais
formé en bêtise on va évidemment parler
de ce discours de politique de ces
discours de politique générale 1 devant
les députés l'autre devant les sénateurs
est ce qu'on n'était pas un peu et hier
stanislas guérini plutôt dans le
catalogue de mesures que dans une vraie
vision de la france sur les cinq ans à
venir non je crois pas je crois au
contraire que les abbés de bornes elle a
fait la parfaite démonstration entre
différence qui avait entre le compromis
et la compromission serre que l a
présenté une vision du pays fidèles à
nos engagements nos engagements de la
campagne la campagne présidentielle
certains éléments je suis certain qu'on
y reviendra qui ont été précisé qui
étaient extrêmement concret parce que je
crois que ces sacs attendre les français
des réponses concrètes sur l'urgence
climatique sur l'urgence sociale pour le
pouvoir d'achat et puis elle a fait
vivre cet esprit qui doit comment
caractériser ce quinquennat c'est un peu
l'esprit du sénat aussi esprit de
compromis elle a donné les points de
verture et points d'intérêts qui avait
eu dans les discussions avec les
différents groupes parlementaires parce
qu'elle a consacré beaucoup de temps
qu'on n'avait réuni que ses erreurs et
c'est comme ça qu'on va devoir avant
sont promis était un mot-clé ensemble
aussi il a été cité 25 fois ça égale le
record du mot territoire dans le 17
pouces et son épée impose je crois
vraiment à ça on a bien on a bien saisi
mais ce qu'on a moins saisi c'est sur
quoi le gouvernement était prêt à lâcher
pour justement aboutir à ce compromis ça
c'est une discussion qu'on aura vraiment
sur les différents textes la situation
politique c'est celle là aujourd'hui
nous avons des oppositions qui ont dit
clairement nous pas participer à un
accord de gouvernement veut pas
participer à une coalition parlementaire
il ya pas eu de bouger entre les
différents groupes parlementaires et ça
nous renvoie donc à une situation où
c'est sur chacun des sujets sur chacun
des textes on va devoir justement
construire ces compromis là est-ce que
c'est malsain est-ce que c'est inédit
par rapport à ce que vivent d'autres
pays je crois pas je crois que ça va
nous obliger à aller chercher le
meilleur de nous même avoir à chaque
fois une direction claire on est la
question du pouvoir d'achat nous notre
philosophie c'est la valorisation du
travail les mesures qu'on met sur la
table ce sont des mesures de
valorisation de travail nous partager la
valeur dans les entreprises augmenter la
prime macro et sas et la philosophie
de la fonction publique
vous êtes certaine si ça s'inscrit dans
ce cadre là et cette cohérence là de
faire des choses aujourd'hui qui
permettent de répondre à l'urgence
donner du pouvoir d'achat aux français
et en même temps ne pas trahir une
philosophie de valorisation du travail
alors oui bien sûr donc les baisses
d'impôts prônée par les républicains par
exemple vous y êtes attentif on
regardera tous effectivement dans un
cadre est là aussi qu'à poser
extrêmement clairement il y avait deux
bornes hier pas d'augmentation d'impôts
pas de déficit excessif et donc une
ligne budgétaire de baisse des déficits
et puis les mesures systématiquement en
faveur de l'environnement enfin que une
fois côté dans ce cadre là alors oui on
peut tous regardé la première
ministrable inciter et salue et vous
l'avez rappelé des échanges avec tous
les présidents de groupe à l'assemblée
sauf sauf ceux du r'n et 2 et les filles
est ce que ça veut dire que vous les
exclus et du champ républicain et du
dialogue en tout cas des partis qui
s'inscrivent dans les partis de
gouvernement
c'est absolument évident on a été
extrêmement clairs nous n'allons pas
chercher de compromis justement d'accord
de coalition avec l'extrême droite dans
notre pays suite on constate qu'au sein
de la du ps et a beaucoup
d'hétérogénéité je pense que pour être
très sincère tout le monde n'est pas
très à l'aise
ni sur la forme ni sur le fond avec ce
qui est proposé aujourd'hui par la
nouvelle au sein même de la dépêche on
verra on verra comment est-ce qu'on peut
essayer d'aller convaincre les
réformistes et moi hier ça veut dire
clairement que c'est vrai qu'on est sur
les divisions de la nuque pour pour
avancer pas des divisions en tant que
tel mais moi je compte sur les voix
réformiste pour d'une certaine façon se
réveiller parfois et prendre des
positions un peu différente de celle et
sur la forme et sur le fond qui ont été
affichées pour l'instant par la du ps
hier en regardant nos oppositions
j'étais parfois attristé et inquiète
attristé de voir qu'au fond elle est
finie entraîne l'intégralité de la nuque
baisse vers le bas dans son attitude
voyez voir des députés danube s ne pas
se lever pour saluer edith cresson
ça m'a fait mal d'une certaine façon
dans un moment où la première ministre
reconnaissait et salué l'engagement des
femmes dans la vie politique simone veil
personne ne se lève ça ne ressemblait
pas aux députés socialistes par exemple
que je connais et puis inquiète inquiet
parce que je vois tout ça fait le jeu au
fond du rassemblement national on a une
stratégie député du rassemblement
national d'être respectable plutôt calme
dans l'hémicycle de voir toutes ces
outrances la côte et de la nuque mais je
me disais au fond que ça profitait et
potentiellement que ça pourra profiter
au rassemblement national et oui ça ça
m'inquiète donc nous nous avons une
ligne sont en train de respectabiliser
le front national en ce sens vers
tel-aviv wazlax et leurs stratégies et
sont tombés dans une outrance absolue
dans des excès absolus ce n'est pas très
digne le spectacle est fière que nous
avons vu à l'assemblée nationale et j'ai
très très peur que tout ça au fond
effectivement banaliserait spectabilis
ce paquet les termes qu'il faut utiliser
le rassemblement national oui ça ça
m'inquiète et oui notre majorité à les
aider
la voir à tj de marine le pen a
contrario est la bonne en tout cas je
vois qu'elle peut avoir une efficacité
et ça m'inquiète parce que quand
l'extrême droite gagnent des sièges
c'était aussi ce qui est ressorti cette
arnaque sur législatives évidemment ça
dois m'amuser x 10 2 fois 10 tout en
touchant des républicains donc ça doit
rester notre combat moi je n'oublierai
pas notre combat principal c'est de
lutter contre l'extrême droite en
parlant d'outrance une peut-être une
petite réaction à la polémique qui est
née des propos de ma type de panneau la
présidente du groupe et les fille qui a
parlé d'elisabeth bande comme une
rescapée de la deûle à la macro ni alors
qu'on le sait c'est une fille de d'un
rescapé des camps de la mort est ce que
vous considérez que c'est une maladresse
c'est une je l'espère je l'espère
vraiment douté vite vite qu'elle
s'excusait qu'elle corrige ses propos
j'espère vraiment du fond du coeur je le
crois que c'est une maladresse
assez terrible parce que un discours de
cette nature là il est préparé il est
lui il est relue elle connaît
parfaitement l'histoire des avait deux
bornes elle a écouté les abbés de bande
pendant le discours de politique
générale qui a évoqué elle-même son
histoire personnelle commet à laisser un
tel mot ensuite dans le discours donc je
crois et d'une certaine façon c'est ma
nature
de penser le meilleur pour chacun donc
je crois que c'est de la maladresse mais
vite qu'elles corrigent évident qu'elles
s'excuseront voilà on va revenir sur le
sur le fond mais sur la forme parce que
là aussi il ya des compromis qui vous
sont demandées notamment par les
sénateurs qui ont demandé
hier est-ce que vous renonciez à ce que
le gouvernement renonce au conseil
national de la refondation est ce que
vous êtes prêts à faire ça et à y
renoncer et à dire mais finalement c'est
au parlement de jouer et il faut bien
expliquer ce qu'est le conseil national
la refondation
les sénateurs se disent peut-être cela
parce que ils ont une vision qui
peut-être met en concurrence les formes
de démocratie les unes avec les autres
ce qu'il faut expliquer c'est que la
démocratie représentative
issu des élections elle sera absolument
pas affaibli par une capacité en amont
sur certains sujets à trouver des voies
de consensus avec la société civile avec
des gens qui sont pas tout le temps
autour de la table dans les discussions
qu'on peut avoir et dans ce quinquennat
moi je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
qui peuvent se faire hors les murs de
l'assemblée nationale et c'est
absolument pas un affaiblissement de
l'assemblée nationale qu'il faut pas y
renoncer parce que la sas absolument pas
voilà dix ans thierry ménard a lancé
avancez c'est de se dire au fond à
l'assemblée dans nos assemblées il faut
se concentrer sur l'essentiel sur les
urgences sur le noyau dur de l'intérêt
général
les questions de pouvoir d'achat
répondre à l'urgence climatique donner
des moyens aussi pour maintenir l'ordre
dans notre pays ça je crois sur ces
sujets là il ya vraiment et je le pense
très sincèrement on est dans cet esprit
de compromis que j'évoquais la capacité
à bâtir des majorités à assembler et
puis il ya beaucoup de choses qui
devront se faire différemment que le
premier quinquennat sur le terrain par
les rifts l'expérimentation par la
différenciation territoriale aussi par
une capacité de dialogue un peu
inventive avec des acteurs qui sont pas
tous temps autour de la table pour
pouvoir avancer c'est vrai sur l'école
c'est vrai sur la santé voyez sur la
santé il ya des mesures immédiates qu'on
peut prendre sans avoir besoin de passer
par l'assemblée nationale
sur l'accessibilité des services publics
jugés sur le conseil national de la
refondation qui avait été prévu au
départ sur fin à fin juin et ce qu'on
veut on peut s'y attendre quand même
pour un lancement de ce mois de juillet
je pense que des possibles mais ce sera
la décision du président de la
république et de la première mise dès
que possible réunissons le conseil
national de cette fondation justement
pour poser le diagnostic
le premier objectif c'est dans le moment
notre pays et notre continent est en
train de yves de poser un diagnostic et
une vision partagée du pays ne
sous-estimons pas l'ampleur des
transformations des chocs que notre
société est en train de vivre je pense
que nous sommes vraiment un moment de
bascule on le voit avec la guerre sur
notre continent on le voit aussi avec
l'impact de toutes ces transitions très
profonde écologiques économiques
démographiques numérique bien c'est à ça
qu'on doit répondre et je pense que le
conseil national euros fondation il doit
placer le débat et notre pays à cette
hauteur là parce que on se tromperait
est vraiment très très profondément si
on restait enfermé voyez dans des
batailles
d'étiquettes d'appareils notre époque
j'ai envie de dire mérite mieux que ça
sur la réforme des retraites peut-être
un bon puisque élisabeth berniard elle
n'a pas du tout parlé d'eux report de
l'âge de départ à la retraite est ce que
c'est un peu une façon d'enterrer cette
mesure quand l'anneau je crois
sincèrement parce que je ne souhaite pas
elle a posé un cadre qu'est celui la
transformation et les réformes pour
notre pays pour pouvoir faire en sorte
que nous financions le progrès ni par
les augmentations d'impôts ni par
l'augmentation de la dette pour les
générations suivantes rohmer il fallait
travailler plus mais elle n'a pas dit
comment est ce que ça veut dire que vous
cherchez de l'aéroport de las de
travailler plus quand même donc les
choses ont été dites clairement pour moi
évidemment ça reste notre ambition
politique faudra construire le
calendrier voire qu'elles sont là aussi
les voix de compromis pour avoir cette
réforme acceptable et moi je reste
intimement convaincu qu'il faut faire
c'est très évident qu'on reste bien sûr
différentes ont raison c'est bien sûr
l'objectif de relèvement de l'âge de la
retraite oui je le crois très
profondément à la fois pour apporter du
progrès et vous savez que vous dormez
comment vous allez trouver un compromis
parce que la droite ne votera pas si a
pas de report de l'âge légal mais de
l'âge légal au delà de gauche ne votera
pas si on a les groupes politiques les
partis politiques dans la campagne
présidentielle ou législative appelé
aussi de leurs voeux à ce qu'on puisse
travailler plus longtemps c'est pas
seule mesure dans la réforme des
retraites 4-3 aux âges c'est avant tout
une réforme de justice une réforme de
progrès pour qu'on puisse aussi
augmenter les pensions de retraite donc
cet équilibre là on le présentera on
avancera je pense que c'est souhaitable
pour notre pays petite question sur
aussi l'autre annonce forte durant ce
discours c'est l'intention de l'état de
renationaliser edf à l'heure actuelle
simplement pour rappel la france peuvent
l'état français possède 84 % du capital
on porterait à 100% alors dans un
contexte de très grande fragilité un de
l'entreprise première question combien
ça va coûter et deuxièmement est-ce que
ça va s'accompagner comme le redoute les
îles et les syndicats d'une réforme en
profondeur de l'entreprise à cette
annonce là c'est la concrétisation de la
vision qu imposer le président de la
république pendant la campagne la
question de notre souveraineté sur notre
capacité d'indépendance énergétique elle
est absolument centrale et si on veut
avoir les moyens c'est souveraineté
alors on doit être en possession de tous
les leviers notamment de levier cette
belle et grande possession de la tête df
que colossal mais mais l'état est dans
le dernier quinquennat a toujours été au
rendez vous avec edf quand il a fallu
recapitaliser edf ne l'ont fait à
plusieurs reprises pour apporter des
moyens en capital certes sans
augmentation du pourcentage de
possession de la société oui mais l'état
a déjà investi mais de l'argent pour
donner les moyens à edf de conduire
cette politique là mais est venu le
temps d'une planification énergétique
plus volontariste et donc combien ça va
être prise et je n'ai pas la réponse ce
matin je dois bien avouer que ce n'est
pas un dossier que je suis moi
directement et donc je reviendrai pour
vous le dire mais je suis certain que
anne espagne à 20h et pourraient vous le
dira législation et moi je n'aime pas
dire de bêtises le matin à la télévision
mais c'est un investissement qui je
crois est nécessaire pour notre pays
parce que on doit faire cette
planification énergétique à la fois pour
investir dans les énergies renouvelables
dans le nucléaire et à travers cette
décision de nationalisation complète
soul avait souligné de cette grande
entreprise publique eh bien nous nous
donnons les moyens de faire cette
planification énergétique c'est ça en
tout cas pas déçu sur la réforme en
profondeur l'entreprise elle même
demande elle a besoin il reçoit bien et
on les doutes les investissements qui
sont nécessaires qui sont devant l'eau
dans le parc nucléaire dans
l'investissement dans des nouveaux
modèles de centrales plus petit et bien
nous avons besoin évidemment de donner
les moyens et de réformer cette grande
entreprise mais c'est un projet
absolument positif est d'ailleurs tout à
fait entraînant et passionnant pour
votre pays puisque c'est une grande
aventure and the city venise et
j'ai bien entendu j'étais moi ah si vous
savez devant les rangs des communistes
l'assemblée je voyais bien qu'ils
saluent cette décision très fortement
alors il avait les applaudissements
discrets à ce moment là mais attendez
le dos et vous suivez bien en revanche
c'est l'augmentation du salaire des
fonctionnaires c'est une mesure qui
figurera dans la loi pouvoir d'achat qui
est présenté cet après midi en conseil
des ministres citons faire acter cette
appris qu'il serait à travers un décret
nous allons prendre en compte ses débuts
ça veut dire juste pour qu'on soit clair
que tous les fonctionnaires seront
augmentés de 3 et demi pour cent au mois
de juillet même si cette loi pouvoir
d'achat n'est pas votée au parlement oui
et nous en tirons les conséquences dans
le projet de loi de finances
rectificatif donc y aura bien une
discussion budgétaire au parlement cette
question là mais la décision
effectivement un décret il sera pris
aujourd'hui même en conseil des
ministres que je crois que c'est
souhaitable dans notre pays pouvoir agir
rapidement quand on prend des décisions
ça sera fait est un engagement il ya peu
pris avant l'élection présidentielle il
sera traduit dans les actes le plus
rapidement possible moi je souhaite je
l'entends dire c'est pas forcément
aujourd'hui si la décision et je l'avais
annoncé comme tel elle sera effective au
mois de juillet mais je suis en train de
me battre pour que dans les logiciels de
paye ça soit visible sur la feuille de
paye dès le mois de juillet pour la
fonction publique d'état c'est à dire là
où on a la main le plus rapidement
possible ce que je pense que c'est très
important quand on prend des décisions à
l'assemblée en décret en conseil des
ministres ça soit effectif le plus
rapidement possible est visible
mais il a une fiche de paye de juillet
les fonctions les fonctionnaires
hospitaliers satrape ces trois et demi
pour cent d'augmentation il concerne
tous les agents de la fonction publique
tous les agents des trois versants
fonctionnaires comme contractuels on va
le traduire dans les logiciels de paye
sur les fiches de paie le plus
rapidement possible dès juillet pour la
fonction publique d'état je pense plutôt
au mois d'août pour la fonction publique
territoriale et hospitalière mais avec
une effectivité de la mesure là aussi en
juillet cercle aura un effet
sur la feuille de paye au mois d'août
pour tout le monde mais c'est pour tout
le monde au mois de juillet le plus
rapidement possible visible il a fait de
monsieur guérini je peux me faire le
chantre du à moitié vide mais vous avez
vu les dernières prévisions l'insee
5,8 % d'inflation votre hausse du point
d'indicé de 3,5 pour cent elle va être
entièrement mangée par l'inflation mais
d'abord vous me donnez l'occasion de
dire plusieurs choses c'est de décision
c'est la plus forte hausse du point
d'indicé depuis 1985 c'est une chose qui
est après extrêmement de plusieurs
années de jeunesse un indice dans ce
quinquennat dans le quinquennat
précédent donc c'est un effort collectif
pour nous tous extrêmement important 7,5
milliards d'euros consacrée justement à
pouvoir apporter une réponse au pouvoir
d'achat des agents de la fonction
publique je veux préciser ici qu'elle
vient s'ajouter s'additionner aux
augmentations moyennes de salaire dans
la fonction publique parce que de temps
en temps donne l'impression 10 ans il ya
eu un gel depuis longtemps du point d'un
disque il ya eu zéro augmentation de
salaire dans la fonction publique c'est
évidemment pas le cas il ya en moyenne
sur ces dernières années 1 25%
d'augmentation des salaires
les agents de la fonction publique dans
les différents vers soyez ambitieux
guérini lui dire que certains ne nous de
nous parler bien cette inflation qui est
en moyenne aussi pour les français donc
à la normale en chine ont brisé la
fonction publique je j'agis pour
l'ensemble des agents donc un ennemi
pour cent d'augmentation moyenne
viennent s'ajouter aux trois et demi
pour cent d'augmentation du projet qui
concerne tout le monde tout de suite
mais elle apporte une réponse je vais
aller au bout parce que c'est
à l'urgence du pouvoir d'achat et j'ai
été très clair avec les organisations
syndicales est-ce que ça épuise la
grande question qui au fond pour moi mon
grand défi ministre et agents de la
fonction publique de l'attractivité de
la fonction publique la réponse est non
nous avons un travail collectif a mené
avec les agents avec des organisations
syndicales sur la conception même des
rémunérations au sein la fonction ça
c'est le travail de cet automne qui me
lisent le mener ce travail là pour
pouvoir aboutir en 2023 parce que je
crois que le chanter l'attractivité de
la fonction publique il est essentiel
pour notre pays on voit bien qu'on a
besoin d'une fonction publique puissant
présente sur les territoires on a besoin
les français savent très bien des agents
de la fonction publique ils font un
travail formidable courageux et s'engage
pour l'intérêt général d'autres pays on
doit répondre et sur la fiche de paye et
ce qui se passe aussi à côté de la fiche
de paye il ya aujourd'hui un déficit de
sens dans l'organisation même du travail
des missions qui leur sont demandés -
c'est sur ces différents éléments là que
je souhaite travailler j'ai encore deux
questions là dessus vous l'avez dit ça
va coûter plus de 5 milliards sur ces 5
milliards il y en a un peu plus de 2 qui
vont être à la charge des collectivités
territoriales est ce que vous allez les
aider à financer sa tournée parce que
j'ai dit on a réuni avec christophe
béchu les employeurs des collectivités
territoriales en amont d'ailleurs de la
décision c'est pas tout le temps comme
ça que ça s'était passé par le passé
d'abord ils ont dit deux choses on est
d'accord pour l'augmentation du point
d'indicé et on est d'accord y compris
pour les proportions que nous sommes en
train d'évoquer ce qui est d'ailleurs le
signe que je crois que c'est un bon
équilibre augmenté de 3 et demi pour
cent puis j'étais d'accord aussi sur la
méthode c'est à dire d'avoir un
rendez-vous budgétaire à l'automne qui
permettent d'évoquer jeune ensemble des
questions de financement pour les
collectivités ce que veulent les
collectivités c'est une vision large
elles ont des enjeux sur la masse
salariale elles ont beaucoup d'autres
enjeux d'augmentation de prix aussi de
fluides d'électricité du gaz dans les
collectivités elles ont des enjeux de
ressources de financement de pérennité
de la dotation générale de
fonctionnement bref donc samuel sarr
entrera dans un cadre global mais qui
aura pas d' aide spécifique à part les
aider sur cette masse salariale
spécifique mais nous aurons une
discussion budgétaire à l'automne et
elle en était d'accord sur la méthode
large et avec l'ambition de donner une
visibilité aussi dans le long terme de
la capacité de projection ce que nous
avons fait dans le quinquennat précédent
sur la dotation générale de
fonctionnement et dernière question
est-ce que ceux des gènes du point
d'indicé il est ponctuel ou est-ce qu'il
va perdurer sur le long du quinquennat
ce que j'ai indiqué là aussi c'est que
soit pleine indexation du point d'indicé
sur l'inflation dont il n'ya pas non
plus de revoyure haddock sur le point
d'indicé
mais on aura un travail je les ai
indiqué sur la construction des
rémunérations les perspectives de
carrière dans la fonction publique qui
sera un travail extrêmement important et
qui donnera évidemment des points de
rendez vous avec tous les acteurs les
organisations syndicales mais aussi les
agents eux-mêmes
avant de laisser les questions
politiques à julien le sénat vous l'avez
vu à présenter une proposition de loi
sur les cabinets de conseils pour mieux
encadrer le recours au cabinet de
conseil suite à la commission denquête
c'est une proposition qui est soutenu
par l'unanimité du sénat ce que le
gouvernement va la soutenir tout cas
c'est une profession je prends très au
sérieux je recevrai d'ailleurs les deux
sénateurs sénatrices et sénateurs qui
sont porteurs de cette propulsion là
dans les tout prochains jours je crois
que c'est une vraie question le recours
aux prestations de conseil moi je veux
pas être populiste voyez je pense qu'il
ya besoin que l'état puisse s'appuyer
sur des acteurs extérieurs pour l'aider
à avancer mais qu'effectivement nous
avions à avancer à clarifier le cas sur
ces questions là et donc ce que je peux
vous dire aujourd'hui c'est que oui il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de propositions
j'avais lu avec beaucoup d'attention le
rapport de ces sénateurs qui formulaient
un grand nombre de propositions que je
reprendrai nous sommes en train de
travailler un nouveau cadre pour
encadrer le recours des ministères à ses
prestations de conseil en stratégie
notamment et se présenter quand son
intégra je le présentais vraiment dans
les prochaines semaines et puis je
donnerai aussi une position sur la
proposition de loi qui sera présenté au
sénat fin qui a été déjà été présentée à
bien vouloir prendre et peut-être pas
tel quel mais que vous reprendrez des
agréments fait trois saisons
beaucoup d'éléments sur lequel on se
retrouvera avec les sénateurs pour
réintégrer leur profession notamment en
matière de déontologie de transparence
de contrôle aussi dans le cadre de ses
prestations là donc on va avancer très
fort et je pense que voilà un sujet sur
lequel on peut avancer ensemble créé
justement de l'unanimité c'est ce que je
souhaite à ce qu'il ya besoin il faut
pas laisser ce débat aux populistes qui
en font toujours mauvaise usage d'une
certaine façon pour abîmer pour
décrédibiliser et à beaucoup de gens qui
veulent bien faire au sein de l'état je
peux vous le garantir
c'est pas malsain de parfois recourir à
un prestataire extérieur mais bien sûr
il faut encadrer les choses et surtout
réarmer notre état réarmer notre
puissance publique avec des capacités en
interne des compétences pour justement
prendre des décisions stratégiques
oui simplement sur la le futur de
renaissance ex et l'hérault m 12 vous
êtes le délégué général alors déjà d'une
jusqu'à quand vous l'êtes est ce qu'il
ya une date à laquelle vous abandonnez
cela ce siège le calendrier qu'on a
discuté avec taux de bureau exécutif
cette semaine c'est un calendrier qui
consisterait à
réunir les trois formations politiques
agir territoires de projet et la
république en marge comme un chat
l'inventerait pour avoir un moment de
réflexion collective sur ce que doit
être ce grand parti présidentiel qu'on
souhaite refonder la note sur des bases
saines ya parizon maude-aimée raison ils
sont dans l'opposition et dans la
majorité présentielle dans l'ensemble
mon âme est ensemble ça devient quoi ça
continuera évidemment à exister jorisch
affaire avec toujours les chercheurs je
souhaite en tout cas son rôle est très
important dans de majorité donc si il en
a le souhait elle désire je pense que sa
voix sa sagesse elle est extrêmement
précieuse pour notre majorité donc le
modem horizons et renaissance dans cette
coalition de majorité et puis
renaissance qui est le grand parti
présidentiel sur une base élargie avec
territoire de progrès avec agir s'ils en
sont d'accord avec lui et ce
avec une capacité et ça nous a été
reproché parfois à faire vivre le débat
et fait revivre les sensibilités au sein
cette grande formation en présentiel je
pense qu'il faut pas aller chercher le
plus petit dénominateur commun on est
dans un moment important à un moment où
la bataille des idées ou la définition
aussi à long terme de ce que doit être
le progressisme le maquereau nisme et
bien c'est très important de pouvoir
faire vivre ce débat là dans notre
formation politique donc à la rentrée
oui avec l'objectif effectivement à ce
moment-là officiellement de basculer de
la république en marche en renaissance
mais pas seulement en intégrant des
forces qui veulent venir avec nous fondé
ce grand parti présidentiel des regrets
c'est la fin d'une petite réaction à
l'interview de stéphane séjourner dans
le dans le figaro qui est susceptible de
prendre votre succession et qui dit nous
devons retrouver l'esprit de conquête le
goût du risque le dépassement politique
est-ce que
ouais mais il est patent que se
réveillent un petit peu c'est marrant
mais écoutez moi je suis très fier
d'avoir dirigé une formation politique
qui a permis la réélection du président
de la république c'était inédit dans la
vème république en dehors des périodes
de cohabitation je pense que puis on
perd pas mal de difficultés faut pas se
flageller sur le travail qui a été fait
il ya un travail immense qui a été menée
avec nos militants avec les marcheurs
avec nos cadres et vraiment je veux les
saluer mais bien sûr on doit ce procès
la vie politique du pays et ce travail
moi je le fais avec stéphane ces
journées il mène un travail très
important mais il y aura un homme hanté
rappeur
me sert le mot inventaire parfois on y
met beaucoup de connotation négative moi
c'est avec un esprit extrêmement positif
que je méprise projette dans cette
aventure collective j'y prendrai ma part
d'ailleurs moi je veux pas disparaître
de notre organisation partisane c'est
très important les partis politiques
sont parfois décriées mais ils ont un
rôle très important dans la vie
politique et ce sera loin de là merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité c'est
le tour de france allen de la vraie
d'une invitée chez nous on est un jour
oui des pavés et qui parlait que le
tragique aujourd'hui un bon tour et puis
s'en va c'était la une de la voix du
nord merci beaucoup
[Musique]